bonjour et bienvenue sur my friends
alors les lundis soirs depuis plusieurs
mois maintenant sont des soirées un peu
difficile pour moi c'est le soir ou
jamais en ligne la vidéo du forum la
principale et j'ai incroyablement peur
le livre d'histoire d'avoir dit l'énorme
boulette
du coup je lis avec anxiété vos
commentaires et d'ailleurs j'essaie de
ne pas réagir à vos commentaires parce
que j'ai vraiment envie d'éviter de
réagir à chaud et enchaîner avec une 2e
bêtise du coup les lundis soirs lee
fréquence y était dans le silence vos
commentaires en espérant que dans vos
commentaires vous ne pouviez pas trop
d'erreurs que j'ai pu faire dans la
vidéo
ceci étant dit si vous voyez une erreur
dans une vidéo quelles qu'elles soient
des miennes s'il vous plaît à souligner
l'erreur que j'ai pu faire hier mais et
émotionnelle du lundi soir sont très
secondaire comparé à l'importance parce
que pour moi de ne pas avoir laissé
traîner de grosses erreurs dans ses
vidéos et malheureusement des erreurs
dans mes vidéos a déjà fait pas mal sont
des premiers jumeaux ainsi que 39 et 41
mais au final la plus importante aux
autorités scientifiques à l'époque était
du chêne cette distribution est flou de
l'énergie se doivent d'être décrit par
un tenseur que l'on appelle le temps
soeur stress énergie deux autres
morceaux l'adn de façon naturelle vont
venir se recoller aux compositions
homologue alors ce temps sur têt minutes
les cris de choses d'un côté va décrire
la manière dont la matière se déplace à
travers l'énergie et que ça m'amène à la
question suivante at on le droit de
faire des erreurs
quand on fait de la vulgarisation de on
partage une aventure scientifique ou
plus généralement quand on incarne plus
ou moins les sciences sur de façon
publique
est ce qu'on a le droit à l'erreur il ya
quelques mois j'ai été aux jeux sont des
jeux mathématiques place saint sulpice à
paris c'était vraiment cool et la brèche
j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger avec
plusieurs personnes qui était présenté
dans quelques uns qui connaissent en
soit ça fait un très grand plaisir
et l'une de ces personnes a notamment
suggéré de faire des vidéos qui le gard
is le problème du réchauffement
climatique et le rapport du giec à ce
sujet et je m'étais surpris à ce
moment-là à répondre non non je ne
compte pas faire de vulgarisation du
preuves du réchauffement climatique
parce que en gros je considère qu'on n'a
pas le droit à l'erreur quand on parle
de ce genre de sujet parce que c'est un
sujet à controverse
un sujet peu papa contraire ce sens de
la communauté scientifique mais un sujet
sur lequel bien des gens sont prêts à
bondir et souligner toute petite erreur
toutes petites imprécisions que l'on
pourrait faire dans une vidéo et du coup
fait rare gaffe à ne pas dire des
erreurs je m'en suis pas mal rendu
compte quand j'ai vu la vidéo de veritas
y sommes à ce sujet qui est une
excellente vidéo et qui m'a montré que
m'a convaincu bon vin chaud objectif une
chose mais surtout avec moi m'a
convaincu cette vidéo que je parlais du
réchauffement climatique était bien plus
délicat que ce qu'on pourrait croire
réfuté les arguments des
climato-sceptiques n'est pas si facile
en général cas c'est vraiment ce que m'a
convaincu et ce nombre inclut cette
vidéo de veritas y sommes dans le même
ordre d'idée développe aussi a fait une
superbe vidéo sur le réchauffement
climatique et dans sa vidéo pour autant
que je sache il n'y a pas d'erreur pas
de trucs en tout cas clairement fausse
mais un moment dans sa vidéo il utilise
un graff dont l'accès hors d'eau ne
commence pas à 0 or il ya d'autres
vidéos sur le web de gens très très bien
qui disent que dans un graphe il ne faut
jamais faire partir l'axé des ordonnées
pas à zéro faute sur le fait recommencer
à zéro et que c'est un petit peu
manipulé l'opinion que de choisir de
faire des graphes dans l'axé des
ordonnées ne commence pas à 0 david a
été obligé de décrire un billet
complémentaire à sa vidéo où il explique
pourquoi est ce que selon lui ce n'était
pas manipulé l'opinion que d'utiliser et
autres cas si tu es complètement
injustifiée dans son cas d'utiliser un
grave dans l'axé des ordonnées ne
commence pas à zéro et il le vrai
problème lorsque l'on parle de problèmes
comme le réchauffement climatique si on
fait une toute petite erreur c'est que
les climato sceptiques vont se jeter sur
nous et souligner cette erreur moment
appuyer là où ça fait mal et ainsi
donner l'impression que cette erreur est
en fait révélatrice d'une erreur plus
globale non seulement chez le
vulgarisateur mais aussi au sein de la
communauté scientifique
bref tout parce que l'on parle de ce
genre de sujets qui ont fait une erreur
ou même pas une heure juste un truc qui
va faire parler beaucoup les
climato-sceptiques et qui va leur donner
du grain à moudre pour donner
l'impression qu'ils sont qu'ils ont
raison en tout cas sur un point précis
de fil en aiguille on décrédibilise
ainsi non seulement sa propre personne
mais de fil en aiguille on risque de
décrédibiliser aussi la communauté
scientifique non pas auprès des
scientifiques y ont sans doute l'oeil
pour voir que les argument des climato
sceptiques sont pas valables ou
anecdotique mais aux yeux de ceux qui ne
sont pas forcément les scientifiques qui
n'ont pas forcément toutes deux tout le
recul sur ce hors de question dans ce
genre de vidéos où on va avoir pas mal
de réactions critiques qui visent non
seulement la personne qui a fait la
vidéo mais aussi toute la communauté
scientifique de fil en aiguille je
considère pense qu'on n'a vraiment pas
trop le droit à l'erreur
en tout cas on n'a pas le droit aux
grosses erreurs alors bien sûr
réchauffement climatique c'est un
exemple du pub le mans je dirais que
tous les sujets qui sont vraiment à
contreverse qu'on a vraiment des gens
qui sont anti et qui définit lui sont
plus tout même quasiment anti science
une chance commandes est par exemple
sensible à xi nation
les médicaments l'homéopathie par
exemple ou encore parler du racisme ça
techniquement on peut traiter tous ces
sujets de façon scientifique
on peut en parler dans la vue est
magnifique aussi mais il faut aussi
faire super gaffe quand on parle de ces
sujets que ne pas dire de boulettes pour
ne pas donner de soupçons sur la
crédibilité des sciences donc voilà une
chance qu'il ya des sujets sur lesquels
on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur
des sujets vous faut vraiment faire bien
son travail être super et goro quasiment
sur tous les mots qu'on utilise faire
bien en sorte de mettre toutes les
sources etc
ceci étant dit je pense que dans
d'autres sujets comme la physique
théorique et les mathématiques
c'est un peu l'un vers ce qui se passe
et ce que je vais essayer de faire dans
le reste de cette vidéo c'est de vous
convaincre que ce n'est pas grave du
tout de faire des erreurs
quand on parle de physique théorique
notamment une de mathématiques voir que
c'est bien d'en faire
en tout cas il faut prendre plaisir à
faire des erreurs en maths et en
physique
je pense qu'on vit pas mal dans une
société aujourd'hui où l'erreur est très
mal vu et où on cherche absolument à
avoir raison avant tout et je pense que
cet état d'esprit est absolument pas
sain il est même très malsain quand on
fait des mathématiques ou la physique
lorsqu un esprit il nous vient sans
doute en partie des hommes politiques
qui cherchent toujours avoir raison ça
nous vient aussi carrément de
l'éducation notamment de l'éducation en
maths et en physique ce qui est vraiment
très intéressant c'est que l'éducation
telle qu'elle est faite aujourd'hui en
maths et en physique cherche avant tout
à promouvoir le fait d'avoir raison à de
donner la bonne réponse
du coup diabolise devoir stigmatise
l'erreur faite c'est de faire une erreur
ce mal fait de faire des erreurs d'être
imprécis c'est très très très vue en
cours de mathématiques
aujourd'hui alors moi personnellement
j'ai eu la chance de faire un peu de
recherche en mathématiques à très haut
niveau
j'ai côté des très grands chercheurs et
ont détruit qui m'a pas mal marqué chez
grands chercheurs c'est le art obsession
pour l'intuition plutôt que pour le
formalisme et et la rigueur et de façon
plus générale moi quand je parle de ma
recherche un autre chercheur j'utilise
constamment des concepts qui sont floues
imprécis qui sont pas formalisés je sous
entends à chaque fois n'assure qu'il est
une façon de formaliser tout ça mais la
façon naturelle de parler notamment
lorsqu'on fait vraiment de la recherche
et qu'on ne sait pas encore exactement
où est ce qu'on va en venir et
incroyablement flou incroyablement
imprécise incroyablement erronée et
c'est incroyablement utile de passer par
cette étape à mon sens pour pouvoir
progresser en mathématiques ce soit au
niveau de la recherche mais aussi au
niveau de l'école il est indispensable
de se mettre à parler des mathématiques
de manière très très très erronée faire
des erreurs ça fait partie de la manière
dont on apprend les mathématiques
donc c'est vraiment mathématiques le
français aimerait un peu dans toutes les
sciences et à ce sujet il ya
d'excellentes vidéo de veritas yonne
dans celles où ils interviewent d'autres
youtuber en leur posant des questions
dans cet épisode où cet épisode est ce
que je trouve vraiment génial dans ces
épisodes c'est non seulement on voit des
gens se tromper les gens très
intelligents se tromper ça c'est
toujours ça permet toujours de
relativiser ses propres erreurs mais
aussi et surtout on voit le plaisir des
gens qui se trompent
on voit à travers cette vidéo qu'il ya
un vrai un vrai bonheur un vrai bonheur
à ce trou à lundi dernier si vous l'avez
vu j'ai fait un épisode sur à la manière
dont anne chic and a découvert la
théorie de la relativité générale depuis
quatre ans en équations de la relativité
générale et cette aventure d'einstein
est truffé d'erreurs quoi einstein et
justes en chine et erreur sur erreur je
n'ai pas tout mis dans cette vidéo de
mais il ya beaucoup plus d'erreurs
encore il essayait de justifier le fait
par exemple que ces équations n'est
valable que dans certaines cartes de
l'espace temps et pas dans d'autres
car de l'espace quand des trucs qui
d'autre on sait aujourd'hui que c'est
complètement faux et einstein fait plein
de trucs complètement fourche
mais c'est comme ça qu'on avance en
sciences il n'aura jamais obtenu sa
négation de relativité générale s'il
n'avait pas fait toutes les erreurs
qu'il avait fait je pense qu'il n'y
serait pas arrivé non plus n'avait pas
su prendre un certain plaisir à faire
des erreurs
notre conséquence à ces fâcheuses du
fait que en impression en mathématiques
en physique en particulier on va se
faire encore plus taper sur les doigts
si on veut on dit des trucs faux et
malheureusement ça c'est le cas parce
que pas mal de puristes un temps je vois
parfois dans mes commentaires qui ainsi
sur notre truc de fait que tel truc que
j'ai dit est faux oui je sais que j'ai
dit plein de trucs faux mais le danger
trop insister d'être un puriste à trop
insister sur des détails techniques qui
finalement ne sont pas importantes
big picture c'est que on fait vraiment
peur non mathématicien et au nom
physicien et les inhibe ça c'est le plus
gros danger des pires choses qui
puissent arriver pour l'éducation
mathématiques sens très large
c'est le fait que les gens n'osent plus
parler de mathématiques puis on l'a vu
c'est en parlant de mathématiques de
façon souvent très ironique on fait des
progrès et malheureusement aujourd'hui
je pense que très peu de vulgarisateur
ose parler de mathématiques donc je
pense aux vulgarisateur qui font par un
peu de toutes les sciences c'est
vulgarisateur là qui parle de tout les
sens ils ne sont pas physicien
théoricien nous signerons pas
mathématicien bien souvent ils ne vont
pas parler de mathématiques et c'est ça
le pire du pire drame
vous prenez un fiancé vivre moi j'étais
gamin que je lisais sens et vie je
trouvais ça un tableau frustrant qui
avait pas de maths mon sens et vie
du coup je me donne l'impression qu'il
avait pas de recherche en mathématiques
pas de choses intéressantes aux
mathématiques ou jeux mathématiques
c'était juste pour l'école c'est
vraiment là dans le film j'en profite
pour vraiment encouragé tous les
vulgarisateurs scientifiques tout ce qui
parle de science de manière publique a
parlé aussi et beaucoup si possible de
mathématiques quitte à faire quelques
erreurs si vous avez peur de faire des
erreurs d'être imprécis ou de faire des
contresens n'hésitez pas à m'envoyer vos
scripts je serais heureux de vous aider
à parler de mathématiques parce que je
pense que c'est super important de voir
des noms matheux parler de mathématiques
et un enfant sur tout ça est juste une
conséquence du fait qu' à trouve de
puristes en mathématiques et qu'on
cherche trop à éviter l'erreur en
mathématiques
or savez que l'erreur que l'on progresse
et du coup il faut absolument prévoir
les erreurs et je trouve ça au final
avec le recul quasiment cool en fait
d'avoir fait des offres 60 folle de
montrer que mathématicien c'est pas un
mec qui dit que détruit devrait
contrairement à ce qu'on dit très
souvent on disait que ce qui ne fait pas
d'erreur c'est celui qui n'a jamais rien
essayer de nouveau et malheureusement
quand il s'agit de maths les gens ne
jamais rien essayé de bouger parce
qu'ils ont trop peur des erreurs donc
voilà donc pour résumer tout ce que j'ai
dit et sortir une phrase qui j'ai un peu
travaillé vous pourrez a cité dans ce
topic français je rêve je dirais que la
chose suivante dire vrai sans raison on
triomphe sans gloire et à dire faux avec
raison on s'incline avec une gloire
triomphante glace était vraie force nc
sur les erreurs ça vaut ce que ça vaut
est votre avis qu'on peut - en tant que
lien donc je vous invite à le mettre
dans les commentaires